the realm
do you know what the realm is
[Music]
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones season
8 episode 5
trailer breakdown video well it's about
that time my friends we are only days
away from finally getting to see
daenerys targaryen fight cersei
lannister for the iron throne
this would have once been a very easy
victory for daenerys targaryen but it
might not be so easy anymore
as we all know dany had three dragons
and a very large army but thanks to the
night king and even euron greyjoy to
some extent
she now only has one dragon and about
half of the army she once had
cersei has the iron fleet the golden
company and she has
anti-dragon weapons on the iron fleet
and set up around the entire city
this should make for one hell of a
battle at the beginning of the new
trailer we can see daenerys targaryen
overlooking the ocean
my guess is this is also at the
beginning of the episode before she
attacks king's landing
obviously she has a lot to think about
before she brings fire and blood to the
capital
like i said in my last video dany really
got her ass kicked in the last episode
after the battle for winterfell they
held a ceremony for everyone that died
fighting in the battle
dany had to say goodbye to one of her
closest friends and advisor sir jorah
mormont
after that during the celebration danny
saw how everyone acted around jon snow
they all love him and they look at him
as their leader although danny damn near
sacrificed everything she had they still
look at her like the outsider
danny already knows if they all find out
jon had the rightful claim to the iron
throne they would want to get rid of her
as soon as they could
they would rather see jon as their king
even if he doesn't want it
sansa stark and varys are already trying
to take the iron throne away from dany
not only that but it's also clear that
dany still loves jon
only he doesn't seem to want to stay in
the same kind of romantic relationship
they once had
now that dany is finally getting ready
to claim the iron throne she has to
worry about
all this other stuff at the same time
unfortunately it only gets worse
right as dany and some of her men are
about to land back on dragonstone her
other dragon rhaegal gets shot right out
of the sky in front of dany
now she only has one dragon then dany's
only other very close friend gets
captured
and beheaded right in front of danny as
well i mean
holy [ __ ] i was so mad at cersei in that
moment i wanted danny to bring fire and
blood to king's landing immediately
so i can only imagine what dany had to
be thinking after she saw that
daenerys is in a very fragile state of
mind as of right now
these are all the things danny is
thinking about when we see her at the
beginning of the new trailer
she's thinking about her dead friends
her dead dragons her and jon snow's
relationship
and many other things it looks like
danny is a mess
which is completely understandable as
soon as jon snow does get down there as
well as the rest of their soldiers we
will see the battle begin
now someone actually sent me a message
and they said they thought daenerys
looked like she might be pregnant in the
photo
i'm not so sure about that because there
haven't been any signs of this during
the new season
by the end of season 7 i would have
guaranteed dany would have a baby
because there was so much foreshadowing
last season
dany said she can no longer have kids
many different times and even jorah
mormont made that comment to jon snow
about him having kids
it really felt like they were setting
this up for the final season
you want to know who sits on the iron
throne after i'm dead is that
it you say you can't have children
but there are other ways of choosing a
successor
i've forfeited the right to claim this
soul
it's yours it'd serve you well
and your children after you
the dragons are my children they're the
only children i'll ever have
do you understand
i was hoping they would have a kid
together otherwise there may no longer
be a house targaryen in the future
however only looking at the photo i
can't really say
danny hasn't shown any signs of this as
of yet so i would be a little shocked if
it happened this late into the season
i guess we shall see now look at the
next image
that one could be very symbolic it looks
like he is walking right into the mouth
of a dragon
as of right now tyrion lannister
continues to support daenerys targaryen
but i don't think he will be by the end
of the battle
varys is already trying to get him to
betray dany i believe it's only a matter
of time before we see that happen
daenerys will have to have them executed
for treason
and we all know how danny likes to
execute her enemies
that photo could be a glimpse of how his
story comes to an end
next we have cersei lannister
overlooking king's landing
and i really hope the evil [ __ ] gets a
good look at the city because this will
be the last time she ever has the chance
alright so now it looks like we are
moments away from the battle
jon snow tyrion lannister davos and the
rest of the soldiers have now made it
outside of the city gate
right on the other side is the golden
company who are ready to fight
this is about to be a bloodbath now let
me tell you what concerns me about the
photo
do you remember when jon went out beyond
the wall to capture a white
remember all those badass characters
that were with him he had barrack
dondarrion sandor clegane
jorah mormont and he had giants bane now
do you remember who was all at the
battle for winterfell
he had jaime gendry brienne arya jorah
barrick
and so many others helping him fight
that battle now look who is standing
next to jon in this photo
he might as well be standing there alone
i don't like that i don't like that at
all
now thankfully danny still has half of
her soldiers and drogon
you cannot see him in the photo but
there is one other character that can be
jon's right-hand man during the battle
in fact this other character is so angry
he might even be able to make up for all
the other characters who will not be
fighting in the battle
i'm talking about grey worm
unfortunately he had to just sit there
and watch the love of his life get her
head cut off
i'm expecting to see greyworm go crazy
during the battle
i really hope the camera does focus on
him when he's fighting because i want to
see greyworm go on a murder fest
now besides the streets of king's
landing we will also see some fighting
out on the bay
this is where euron has his fleet and
this is where euron can be seen in the
new trailer
this will make the second time we have
seen the blackwater bay on fire
now they never showed daenerys riding on
drogon in the trailer but euron knows
she is coming for him in cersei
they show the clouds in the sky but dany
and drogon are nowhere to be seen
daenerys is about to fall down on them
like thunder i think she will most
likely stay up in the clouds until she
is ready to strike
then i think she will come down so fast
right on top of their heads they won't
even have time to react
you can see euron is trying to keep the
sun out of his eyes as he looks for a
glimpse of the dragon
now i have seen some really crazy
theories about this scene already
some said dany might have another dragon
or drogon is wearing armor but i don't
know about all that
it doesn't seem like we have time to add
any new things that we haven't seen
already
i honestly think daenerys will be very
strategic with the way she strikes this
time
now that she only has one dragon she has
to be extremely careful when there are
that many ballistas aiming into the sky
dany will have to hit hard and fast then
get the hell back up into the clouds to
get some cover
hit and run hit then run hit then run
now i would love to see drogon and some
badass armor but i don't know where they
would find it or get someone to make it
that fast
here in the next photo you can see the
golden company marching in formation
ready for battle
their weapons are very similar to what
the unsolid carry so it should be
interesting to see them go up against
each other
now if you look at the very back of the
photo right down the center
you can see there is someone dressed in
all black and their back is turned to
the camera
they obviously do not want us to see the
characters face but they do want us to
see them which is why they are centered
in the frame
who the hell could that be and why are
they hiding their identity
it looks like they might have been
hiding down one of the alleys waiting
for the golden company to march by
before they walked out
that could be jaime lannister on his way
to cersei or maybe that's arya stark
wearing someone else's face
i don't think it's sandor clegane
because whoever that is looks a lot
skinnier than the hound
my guess would either be jaime or arya
stark in disguise
let me know who you think it could be in
the next photo we go to the throne room
on dragonstone
it's very dark so it's kind of hard to
see who is all in the room
but i can see daenerys sitting on the
throne and what looks like tyrion
lannister standing across from danny
now i'm not exactly sure who is standing
next to him i think it could be grey
worm
i doubt it would be jaime because he's
traveling down the king's road
he would need to get his ship to get the
dragonstone and since he's heading to
king's laning for cersei
it really doesn't make much sense for
him to go there i don't think it's varys
either mostly because of the shape of
the body
i'm just gonna say it's grey worm
because i know he will be there before
or after the battle if that is grey worm
he will absolutely feed right into
danny's emotions
grey worm wants vengeance from a sand
day he will want to see cersei
the mountain and whoever else gets in
his way to suffer for what they had done
this next photo might be from the same
scene based on the look on his face
i'm guessing daenerys just said
something to make him react like that
maybe danny has found out varys is
talking [ __ ] behind her back
that might also be why we do not see
varys in any other photos
he might have even left dragonstone in
the middle of the night so
since varys and tyrion are so close
danny might be wondering if she can
still trust him or not or maybe she's
talking about burning down king's
landing
it's very hard to say but it doesn't
seem like tyrion likes whatever she just
said
either way the next episode is about to
be crazy arya stark is on her way to
kill cersei
sandor clegane is on his way to kill his
brother jaime lannister is on his way to
kill cersei
daenerys is on her way to kill cersei
and euron john and greyworm are there
with an army to kill all the golden
company
also daenerys has to worry about varys
and sansa trying to take the iron throne
away from her
and we have to see how all the
characters react when and if daenerys
does burn down the red key
i'm very excited let me know what you
think will happen in the next episode
leave me some comments down below
thanks for watching the video and i also
want to thank everyone for supporting
the channel
i hope you have a great day i'll see you
again very soon
bye
[Music]
so
you